Good morning, John!
I spent a bunch of time at the DFTVA.com Warehouse this week,
because it's gettin' into the busy season!
Not that they don't have it handled.
I mostly just sign.. stuff.
It is a really big place,
filled with a bunch of really cool stuff!
We work with a ton of amazing creators now:
Hannah Hart,
and Rhett and Link,
and Glozell Green,
and MinuteEarth,
and This Star Won't Go Out.
We sell shirts,
and hats,
and posters,
and mugs,
and tea...
And, I'm just happy that we get to send people stuff that they like;
and help creative people do what they want to do for a living.
And today,
the day after Thanksgiving,
I'm actually recording this on Thanksgiving.
And also, the day after, John,
you made a video about how we are apparently incapable of understanding how
good the world is, comparatively.
I gotta say!
Sometimes, it is hard
to keep in mind,
how..
nice your life is.
Like, thought experiment here:
say we cure cancer..
tomorrow.
Mass celebrations!
Right?
Like, people would not be able to stop smiling
for days.
And, for years,
we would continue feeling the amazingness of that achievement.
But, twenty or thirty years later,
we would still know that it was great;
there would be less suffering in the world,
less death.
But, we would normalize;
we'd just live in a world without cancer.
How do I know this, for sure?
Well, it's happened before;
I mean, we used to not have antibiotics and vaccines.
Those things have saved billions-
BILLIONS of lives;
and yet, we go on everyday just sort of thinking:
"Yeah, you know,
antibiotics and vaccines.
They're nice."
But, we aren't deeply and emotionally touched
by the magnificent,
magic
that is this ability
to not die;
the way that humans always used to die!
Another example:
uh- I was born into an America
where
two people could be denied the right to marry,
because of their gender.
And, so was everyone else watching this video,
unless you are less than 6 months old;
in which case,
glpblpblpdpbpgp
bgaaaw!!
But, we've already stopped being excited about that!
And, maybe that's GOOD!!
That we're not designed to say,
"Well, I guess we've done pretty well.
Might as well stop progressing..."
Objectively,
on average, this is the best time to be alive in human history.
I mean, I know I say that as someone who,
like, literally wearing-
like, the most-
preppy thing I've ever worn on VlogBrothers!
It's Thanksgiving!
I'm dressed up.
We have achieved
so much to decrease the suffering of people!!
During my Grandmother's life,
there was a war in which 60 million people died.
million!
My Mother was born into an America
where black people had different schools,
and different bathrooms!
But, it's impossible to go through life feeling all of these accomplishments every second;
and, maybe we shouldn't!
Maybe it's beautiful
that we move on from our successes
and immediately fret over the next giant,
magnificent problem that we have to overcome.
But, if we never look back,
and never think about what we've done;
then it all looks hopeless.
It looks impossible!
Which is why it has to be a mix
of- of dissatisfaction with the way that it is,
and what could be better,
and we have to work for that;
and also recognizing that we've done a great deal of remarkable things,
as a species, and as individuals.
Like, I get to live in a world without smallpox;
and in a world with twenty one pilots songs and pumpkin pie.
One day a year of Thanksgiving,
is not enough days of the year.
This is something that I think
really is powerful,
and motivates me,
and makes me happier and more effective!
Just to be thankful
for the literal billions of people,
who have worked hard to make life better for their children;
ah, euh-
because I'm one of those children!
And I hope
that I can honour the memory of those people;
by both appreciating what they've done,
and also building on it.
John,
I'll see you on Tuesday.
And, in addition to everything at DFTBA.com being 20% off this week,
we also have:
[in a comedic voice] Bobble John;
and also,
Bobble Hank!
[Sound of bobble heads bobbling]
[Hank]: AAAAAH!!!
[Hank voicing Bobble John in an accented voice]: "Why do you look so grumpy?"
[Hank voicing Bobble Hank]: My hair is very, very nice."
[Hank in an accented voice]: You can make us kiss.
[Hank, in his normal voice]: Oh!
That was actually-
[Disgusted] Bleueuagh!!
Don't do that!!
[Music]
[Bobble Hank]: Hello, and welcome to "Dear Hank and John"!
[Bobble John]: Or, as I prefer to think of it, "Dear John and Hank"!
[Bobble Hank]: It's a comedy podcast,
where me and my brother John
answer your questions,
give you dubious advice,
and bring you all the week's news;
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon.
And today,
we're doing it..
[Bobble John]: [In a deep voice] LIVE!!
[Bobble Hank]: Together!!
[Music]